[موسيقى]
خمس سنوات مرت على عوده السينما في
السعوديه عوده شهدت حضورا لافتا للافلام
السعوديه بانتاج وعرض اكثر من ثلاثين
فيلما سينمائيا سعوديا حققت عوائد مليونيه
تحولت عديده مرت بها السينما السعوديه اهم
هذه التحولات 2022 في البحر الاحمر
السينمائي من خلال عرض العديد من الافلام
الطويله في سواء في المسابقه او خارج
المسابقه بعد ذلك في 2023 عرض اكثر من
فيلم سعودي اهمها ستار
وحققت نجاح كبير في شباك التذاكر احنا
عارفين انه العديد من الافلام السعوديه
عرضت لكن كان هناك زي ما نقول حاجز ما بين
الفيلم السعودي وما بين الجمهور السعودي
نجاح ستار من خلال تصدر شباك التذاكر
لاكثر من عشره اسابيع في المركز الاول من
خلال الدخول في التوب 4 اكثر الافلام
السعوديه متابعه
اعاده الحصولات السينما هذا من ناحيه شباك
التذاكر ناحيه اخرى كذلك المهرجانات
السينمائيه عدد من الاسماء المهمه
السعوديه من المخرجين منتظر اعمالهم هذا
العام كنا في البدايه نقول يارب ينزل فيلم
سعودي ما بين هذه الكوكبه من الافلام الان
احنا جدا سعيدين ومتشرفين ان الفيلم
السعودي
متواجد وبقوه ما بين هذه الكوكب الافلام
في اشياء حلوه صارت مع نفس الطرب ما كنا
متخيلينها انه كنا بنقول يا رب يشتغل في
الرياض وجده والشرقيه مثلا الان قاعد
يشتغل في حسب المثال في خميس مشيط في
القصيم في الشمال في الجنوب هذا شيء يدعي
يعني للفخر ويدعونا برضو اننا نجتهد اكثر
نسوي افلام اكثر يعني تواجه ويعجب الجمهور
السعودي او اللي غير سعودي سواء المقيم في
السعوديه او في خارج السعوديه
علي عشان واحده من الشارع يا قليل الاصل
65 دولارا هو اجمالي عدد دور السينما في
السعوديه توزعت في عشرين مدينه وسط اقبال
كبير ومبيعات تذاكر عاليه احنا نشوف من
يوم يعني فيلم مثلا كان اول فيلم سعودي
ينعرض في السينما السعوديه التجاريه ما
بين رولم لفيلم الهامور تقريبا كم اربع
خمس سنوات اعتقد الجمهور وانا وصناع
الافلام نقدر نشوف النقل النوعيه والطفره
النوعيه اللي قاعده تصير من ناحيه انتاج
من ناحيه نص من ناحيه تمثيل من ناحيه
اقبال الجمهور ما الاثر الذي تحققه
الافلام اقتصاديا تساؤل تجيب عليه الارقام
التي حققتها اعلى خمسه افلام سعوديه في
المسطر جاء في الصداره بنحو مليون تذكره
يليه فيلم الهامور ثم فيلم ولد ملكا في
المركز الثالث بينما احتل فيلم شمس
المعارف المرتبه الرابعه واخيرا جاء فيلم
مسامير المركز الخامس ضمن قائمه اعلى
الافلام السعوديه تحقيقا للايرادات الجمله
الوحيده اللي بقول انه انا سعيد كوني شخص
يعني مواطن قبل ما اكون ممثل سعودي اني
انا بحقق امنياتي كمتفرج سعودي بالافلام
اللي انا قاعد اعملها فانا ربعي ممثل بس
ثلاثه رباعي مشاهد فالمشاهد اللي عنده
مستمتع بالاعمال السعوديه اللي بتطلع هيئه
افلام وحزمي دعم لصناع الافلام وقدره
شرائيه عاليه تقف وراء الانتشار السريع
والارقام الكبيره التي حققتها السينما
السعوديه منذ العام 2018
[تصفيق]
من جده سعود الخلف العربيه لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات